President Trump appears to proclaim the
virtues of shooting lysyl straight into
your veins to stop coronavirus but while
the mainstream media criticizes them for
it they do the best they can to sanitize
their own narrative on everything from
travel bans to workplace sexual assault
then North Korean dictator Kim jong-un
and presumptive Democratic presidential
nominee Joe Biden compete to see which
would be world leader can seem the least
Lively CNN humiliates itself again in
crime spikes in lockdown New York all
that and more I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
I have to know do you think that Kim
jong-un is alive or dead let me know in
the comments section I actually can't
make up my mind on that we will examine
regardless of which is true what that
means for the world in just a moment but
meanwhile president Trump wants you to
shoot lysyl directly into your veins
this according to the mainstream media
which took a comment that Trump made in
a press briefing last week and has made
it the biggest headline in all the world
here is president Trump telling you to
inject poison disinfectant with nuts
about in a minute one minute and is
there a way we can do something like
that by injection inside or almost a
cleaning because you see it gets in the
lungs and it does a tremendous number
long so it'd be interesting to check
that so that you're gonna have to use
medical doctors with but it sounds it
sounds interesting to me so we'll see
but the whole concept of the light the
way it kills it in one minute that's
that's pretty powerful okay this is a
classic Trump comment it is a throwaway
if the mainstream media were not so
corrupt nobody would have even thought
twice about this what is the story
President Trump says we now know that
household disinfectants kill the
coronavirus within minutes you know you
spray it on the counter and if the virus
is there it'll kill it within minutes
and we know that UV light might also
kill the corona virus you know sunshine
and that sort of thing that's the actual
story then President Trump goes on to
riff and he says so it'd be amazing if
some way you could get the sanitizer or
the light and use it inside the body and
wouldn't that be amazing I don't know
the doctors all those guys they'll do
the research but I'm just saying it'd be
pretty interesting right
classic president Trump optimism we've
got some hope over here that this will
kill the virus so let's use it inside
our body now literally speaking probably
we shouldn't put Lysol in our body right
okay I don't think anybody is watching
that clip and saying honey get me the
lye cyl so I can shoot it up into my
veins but it's President Trump speaking
loosely perhaps a little too loosely and
MIDI be taking
this is immediate medical advice but
then media they saw something and they
jump on it so all of a sudden Trump and
Lysol or the top trend on Twitter and
the Lysol company is saying don't inject
our product by the way Trump never used
the word Lysol that was just media
creation because it would appear that he
suggested using sanitized household
cleaner and sanitizer inside the body
the next day
president Trump decided to clarify his
remark and he insisted that in the
original comment he was merely being
sarcastic verify your comments about
injections of disinfectant they're quite
not ask you two questions sarcastically
to reporters like you just to see what
would happen now disinfectant for it's
doing this maybe on the hands but work
now this again it's a classic Trump
response right witches don't explain
yourself to these reporters just go and
attack the reporter so as now I was
being sarcastic to reporters like you
you jerks it's your fault sure the media
ran with the story was president from
being sarcastic in the first answer no I
don't think so I think he was being
flippant he was being optimistic he was
being a little loose with his words but
I don't think he was being sarcastic
okay what was it it was a comment that
he didn't articulate that well who cares
who cares right it's is anybody shooting
my soul into their bodies no is
President Trump doing a good job on this
coronavirus thing yes have other people
been much less responsible on this
coronavirus thing yes move on okay also
beyond the mere fact that no one wants
you to inject Lysol into your body the
one thing I'll say in the president's
defense here is we do regularly use
poisons as medical treatments right the
key example of this would be
chemotherapy we inject poison into
people's bodies to kill certain cells
because they'll it will kill the cancer
cells that are rapidly dividing so again
nobody's saying shoot up Lysol however
it's not completely outlandish to use
poisons inside the body or to have some
application of something that would
otherwise be poisonous to to treat a
disease dr. Burks for her
dr. scarf has decided to defend
president Trump I've had privilege to do
media all over the world people may not
have seen me before because it's been
primarily in South Africa and Asia
because I've been working on vaccines
and therapeutics and pandemics around
the globe for a number of years and I
think the media is very slicey and dicey
about how they put sentences together in
order to create headlines I think you
know America we know from Millennials
and other studies that some people may
only read the headlines and if there's
not a graphic they're not gonna look any
further than that and I think we have to
be responsible about our headlines I
think often the reporting may be
accurate in paragraph three four and
five but I'm not sure how many people
actually get to paragraph three four and
five and I think the responsibility that
the press has is to really ensure that
the headlines reflect the science and
data that is in their piece itself I
think that's right I think what she's
saying here is in context Trump looks
pretty good and then out of context you
can take one line and make the
administration response to coronavirus
look crazy which is what the left is one
wanting to do the whole time so the left
they focus on this one narrow thing and
then their narrative is the Donald Trump
is completely insane and terrible and
crazy in so doing the left is sanitizing
their own narrative on some of the exact
same points right because at the same
time that the left is making fun of
Trump for apparently suggesting putting
a disinfectant inside your body and
injecting people with that at the very
same time the left is saying it's a
wonderful idea to inject children with
hormones to block their puberty and make
little boys look more like little girls
consider that fact obviously you never
hear these two stories at the same time
but the exact same left the exact same
media that is saying how crazy it would
be to inject lysyl which it would be is
defending injecting little children with
hormones to turn little boys into
looking more like little girls which is
also completely insane and frankly a
whole lot more insane than the lice
stuff we'll get to more on that in just
a moment because the the entire time
that I think the defining feature of
these news cycles is the left is using
right wing stories to try to sanitize
their own far more egregious narrative
we'll get to that in a second first I've
got to thank a new sponsor our friends
over at red power bikes which is one of
the coolest things I've ever seen
red power bikes especially when you are
holed up at home and you got a you got
to head out to the store because you've
run out of things you got to keep busy
you got to keep entertained whether you
want a new way to commute or you want a
new way to get around the city or to get
around out in nature even with the kids
in tow you have got to try rad power
bikes this thing is unreal
it is a cross between a traditional bike
bicycle that you pedal and a moped but
it does not require a special driver's
license like a moped would you can go up
to 20 miles an hour without pedaling so
you can get out and about without
getting sweaty they are great for
commuting they're great for getting out
on the trail hauling groceries these
days or even transporting your kids on
the back and unlike other ebikes they
are actually affordable plus to show
appreciation for those that serve us red
power bikes is offering $100 off all
ebike purchases for active ex-military
first responders teachers and students
that's a lot of people you know someone
who loves being active outdoors tell
them about rad power bikes they offer
flexible financing for as low as 0% APR
right now for a limited time off or get
a free accessory with the purchase of a
bike so you get a free gift of up to 100
bucks in value and free shipping to the
lower 48 states to get this offer text
the word Knowles to 64,000 do that right
now
text Knowles canna wles to 64,000 that
is Knowles to 64,000 to get that special
offer it is very very cool this is what
the left is doing they are focusing on
some comment out of context to sanitize
their own narrative okay the left has
been wrong on coronavirus from the
beginning forget it forget for a moment
about the Lysol and their own hypocrisy
on on poisonous injections they've been
wrong on coronavirus from the beginning
don't forget initially they criticized
Trump
for over reacting with his China travel
ban then when the story changed they
started criticizing Trump for
under-reacting
and now I kid you not they are trying to
argue both at the same time so Nancy
Pelosi leader of the Democratic Party
Speaker of the House while she is
pushing the no ban act while she is
pushing against president Trump's travel
restrictions she is arguing on CNN that
Trump's travel restrictions did not go
far enough Vice President Joe Biden's
campaign told me earlier this month that
he supported president Trump's partial
travel restrictions on January 31st
blocking foreign nationals from China
from coming to the United States do you
agree that it was the right move by
President Trump at the time well let's
go into the future okay yeah if he
actually tens of thousands of people
were still allowed in from China so it
wasn't as it is described as this great
moment though there were Americans
coming back or green card holders coming
back but there were tens of thousands so
if you're going to shut the door because
you have a valuation of an epidemic then
shut the door what so now Nancy Pelosi
who's been saying we need to keep all
the travel open is saying that not only
should we shut down travel from Chinese
nationals but we should actually strand
Americans in China obviously something
she was not saying at the time at the
very same moment the print that
President Trump shut down the Strava
from China Nancy Pelosi was pushing
something called the no ban Act she
placed it on the calendar as recently as
March 5th for the house to take up
forget end of January forget early
February forget late February March 5th
she criticized at that time president
from travel ban now she thinks that she
we should have stranded American
citizens and green card holders in China
amid an epidemic all but ensuring if
they're in the city of Wuhan that
they're going to get the wolf flu beyond
Nancy Pelosi the
person most clearly flipping on this
subject is Joe Biden and you saw Joe
Biden initially said Donald Trump is
being xenophobic it's not now it's not
the time for xenophobia and his racism
we should not be closing down the
virtual border with China then all of a
sudden he said it was the right thing to
do and nobody's paying attention to Joe
Biden anyway his Joe Biden is sitting on
an armchair in his living room watching
television
babbling incoherently to himself that is
not even the biggest flip-flop that Joe
Biden has had in recent weeks
I'm the coronavirus the biggest
flip-flop for Biden and for the
Democrats has been the me2 movement the
biggest attempt to sanitize their own
narrative has been on sexual assault and
me - so you remember a few weeks ago we
played this accusation that has been
made by a former Biden staffer against
Joe Biden there's new evidence out today
to change that story but here's the
original accusation in case you forgot I
was wearing a blouse and he just had me
up against the wall and the wall was
cold and I remember he it happened all
at once the gym bag I don't know where
when I handed it to him was gone and
then his hands were on me and underneath
my clothes and yeah and then he went oh
he went down my skirt but then up inside
it and he had I traded me with those
singers and um I he was kissing me at
the same time and he was saying
something to me he said several things
and I can't remember everything he said
I remember a couple of things I remember
him saying first like as he was doing it
do you want to go somewhere else and
then him saying to me when I pulled away
he got finished doing what he was doing
and I I was pulled back and he said he
said come on man I heard you liked me
come on man I thought you liked me sure
does sound like Joe Biden you will
remember when this accusation first came
out a few weeks ago I basically defended
Joe Biden here because it sounds it
sounds a little too much like Joe Biden
frankly
and we looked into this woman's story
Tara Reid we saw how the story has
changed over the years we saw a
convenient it is that the story is
coming out now that Biden is running for
president but it didn't come out the
last time he ran or the time before that
how initially she came out and said he
was just sort of inappropriate with her
but then it came out it was this actual
sexual assault so I I don't want
conservatives and Republicans to fall
into the same trap and shallowness and
hypocrisy that the Democrats did on
Brett Kavanaugh I want there to be due
process I want people to take a cold
hard look at the facts and not merely go
with the politically convenient option
here right mind you the allegation
against Joe Biden is by definition much
more credible than the allegation
against Brett Kavanaugh because the
allegation against Joe Biden is coming
from a former Biden staffer whereas in
the case of Kavanagh when it comes to
Christine Blasi Ford or certainly Julie
sweat Nick there's no evidence these
people who never knew Kavanagh at all
there's the even Christine Blasi Ford
who was the star sexual assault witness
for the Democrats couldn't remember
where the party took place when the
party took place how many people were at
the party her own close friend who was
at the party said it didn't happen it
was decades and decades ago nobody ever
heard anything about it there were so
many inconsistencies in her story this
Bisson this allegation against Joe Biden
far more credible and yet I still would
say on the evidence we had a few weeks
ago not the death knell in his coffin
you know not the end of his campaign
however there is new information out
there and it's one of the most bizarre
pieces of evidence you could possibly
imagine to back up this woman's claims
we'll get to that in a second first I
got to thank our friends over at legacy
box you know how difficult it is to shop
for mom very hard right what are you
gonna what are you gonna get your mother
well she's always gonna love pictures of
you isn't she and that's a pretty good
gift
legacy box is the way to do it legacy
box is a super simple mail and service
to have all of your home movies and
pictures digitally preserved on a thumb
drive DVD or the cloud don't let those
priceless family memories disappear
because that's what
happens okay and look they're gonna be
family members maybe they're not with
you anymore a wonderful way that I have
found to preserve those memories is to
use a legacy box I love this thing I
swear by legacy box
here's an idea Mother's Day is
approaching what are you gonna get her
how about you get her memories that will
never get dusty or fade away they help
bring new life to old media by unlocking
those trapped family memories and
putting them in a modern digital format
that is easy to use I love it
I totally trust the service for a
limited time legacy box is running 50%
off Mother's Day special order your
legacy box to take advantage of this
incredible offer this one of the best
discounts they have ever offered 50% off
legacy box is perfect for you or for
someone you love to go to legacy box
comm slash Noel's Cana wles and save 50%
while supplies last I try to be very
fair even to Democrats who were accused
even when it's politically advantageous
this woman makes this allegation will we
need some evidence she gave us evidence
in the form of a clip on Larry King's
old television show so very odd there is
a clip of a woman calling in to Larry
King's old CNN show in 1993 in August of
1993 saying that her daughter just had
this incident with a senior member of
the Senate and was sort of pushed out
because of it and she doesn't know how
to respond the phone call came in from
San Luis Obispo which is the town that
Tara Reid's mother was living in at the
time it came in within days of her
departure from the Biden Senate staff
hears the phone call we're back couple
more phone calls on this very important
topic our guests are former United
States Senator Howard Baker Richard
Allen former national security adviser
and Louis Romano of the Washington Post
San Luis Obispo California hello yes
hello I'm wondering what a staffer would
to do besides go to the press in
Washington my daughter has just left
there after working for a prominent
senator and could not get through with
her problems at all and the only thing
she could have done with those
to the press and she chose not to do it
out of respect for him or she had a
story to tell but out of respect for the
person she worked for she didn't tell
her yeah but these are the people who do
come to the lowest Romano's right the
staff worker who says I want to let you
know about what's going on also the guy
down the hall mm-hmm and a lot of these
people have a sense of obligation they
feel that this public official should be
accountable if it's something they're
whistleblowers to the press exactly this
is a very interesting piece of evidence
because nowhere and there does she say
my name is mrs. Reid nowhere in there
does she say
the senator is Joe Biden we don't know
that it's this woman's mother though
Tara Reid has come out and said this is
my mother on the recording and the
timing matches up in the location
matches up where they found this I have
no idea where they found this Larry King
clip I have a few hunches and we'll get
to that in a second but I don't know for
sure
still we should not fall into the Brett
Kavanaugh Democrat hack trap of saying
Joe Biden is definitely guilty what we
should do very simple hold the Democrats
to their own standards you know if the
left didn't have double standards that
have no standards at all we should hold
them to their own standards we should
see them hoisted by their own petard
they say believe all women but they
don't believe all women they don't
believe the women's staff members of
their own senior officials of their own
Democratic presidential nominee they
won't take this seriously a lot more
evidence here than they ever had against
Republicans and they still won't take it
seriously so we should demand that this
woman gets a fair hearing in the same
way that Christine Blasi Ford got a fair
hearing and the same with a Julie sweat
Nick for goodness sakes who wasn't
credible at all got a fair hearing and
Joe Biden should get a fairer hearing
then then brick Avenue had it's probably
not going to go very well for him where
did this clip come from some people are
saying it came from the right came from
conservatives came from the Trump team
to try to damage their candidate I'm not
so sure about that why would the Trump
team why would the concern
servants release this kind of footage
right now if they were sitting on this
kind of Oppo research why would they
wait to release it right now when they
could wait another four or five months
and release it just before the general
election when it's too late after the
DNC when Joe Biden's already wrapped up
the nomination and then it's too late to
throw them overboard
why wouldn't they wait seems to me much
more likely that this evidence this
allegation is coming from the left
because they know that Joe Biden is too
weak to beat Trump in November look
right now we've got something like 20%
unemployment President Trump should be
losing by triple digits it should be
like zero to 100 against the Democratic
candidate and yet he's not his approval
ratings are doing just fine because Joe
Biden while he's taking his a little
breather at home is decaying he's
getting even worse sitting in his own
living room
he doesn't seem up to the job he can't
remember his own name and Democrats are
freaking out I felt they were freaking
out even during the impeachment hearings
that was what senator Cruz when we were
doing our show verdict said he thought
that the Democrats lost confidence in
Joe Biden and that's why they were
willing to allow certain allegations
against hunter Biden to come out they
were willing to throw Joe over the bus I
think that's clearer now there is still
time for the Democrats to replace Joe at
the top of their ticket and so I think
they are the ones using as much
ammunition as they possibly can to get
him out of there and have him replaced
by a better candidate if it were the
conservatives doing it I think they
would have waited on this until a little
later I think it would have been the
Access Hollywood tape right for
President Trump were there they're
holding this this great piece of dirt on
him and they're gonna release it at the
very end of the campaign of the general
election campaign because the evidence
that Joe Biden is not up to the task is
all around us now even while he's
filming from his living room he can't
speak he can't be trusted to articulate
his own campaign pitch so he's having
his wife do it for him and he's standing
there grinning like a very confused man
and together we're just getting started
this moment reminds us that the
presidency is about true leadership
having the four
thought to prepare for the worst the
backbone to lead through chaos the
character to move beyond politics and
serve every American no matter where
they live or what they believe only one
candidate in this election has all three
my husband our next president of the
United States Joe Biden
the only man who can do this as my
husband Joe Biden and you see Joe
staining extra egos Joe who's that guy
oh gosh I want to meet him he has sounds
oh wait he's me okay uh sorry uh it's
you know the thing you know you know the
thing he looks so confused he looks so
weak standing there next to her
well he's sort of kind of vacant and
just vaguely smiling and then she says
Joe Biden he kind of smiles a little
more and well if you're the man
to do it then you need to be able to
speak you need to be able to lead you
can't hide behind your consultant so
we're doing your social media and your
wife who is speaking for you on camera
and everybody else while you cower in
your living room it's not a good look
it's not inspiring confidence and right
now Joe Biden doesn't need to inspire
confidence among me certainly I'm not
gonna vote for him he's not gonna
doesn't need to inspire confidence even
among the middle yet or the independence
he's got to inspire confidence among
Democrats who still haven't nominated
him I know we're pretending like he's
already got the nomination there will be
a convention at which he accepts the
nomination and if something happens
before then where Biden this doesn't
have the stamina to get it somebody else
is gonna step in and I suspect in the
upper echelons of the smoke-filled rooms
of the Democratic Party there are a lot
of discussions going on not not because
it's likely or probable that Joe is
going to be replaced but because it's
certainly plausible at this moment and
it would probably help them out and I'm
sure there are contingency plans being
made and I'm sure that North Korea
wishes they made some contingency plans
if they're a Dear Leader fell apart
because Kim jong-un the leader of North
Korea has not been seen for weeks and
there's a lot of speculation that he's
dead and we don't know if he's dead or
not
and I would certainly like to hear your
opinion on it because we really don't
know obviously his not being present for
key military functions for major
ceremonies for the anniversary of the
North and South Korean leaders meeting
at the DMZ I mean that's pretty weird
they didn't show up for that so he's
obviously in some strange health state
right now and he might be dead but he
might not be dead because the fact that
there are no particularly strange
goings-on among the the North Korean
government right now according to
Japanese and South Korean media suggests
maybe he's not totally dead yet they
probably would move to seize power
quickly if he were totally dead so
anyway we're just in the midst of
uncertainty there so much uncertainty
today in in the world with coronavirus
and everything else that's not the point
I don't really care if Kim jong-un is
alive or dead I
North Korea is going to be a disaster
regardless my point is the left's
reaction to the possibility of Kim Jong
Un's death because if Kim jong-un dies
then his sister is reportedly going to
take over for him and his sister is one
of the scariest people you've ever seen
you remember at the Olympics a few years
ago she came out that was her big reveal
to the world and this woman looks like
like the devil you know she just looks
like the coldest ice queen psycho like I
guess like the rest of her family but
she's just the female iteration of that
and the leftist media fond over her this
woman who is keeping millions of people
in prison in North Korea this woman who
has people executed this woman who lies
on behalf of one of the worst regimes in
history of the world because she is a
woman and because the left is so
enthralled to identity politics they
celebrated her and they got roundly
mocked at the time well guess what
they're doing it again Saif Abramson an
actual prominent leftist journalist with
a blue checkmark who writes for newsweek
tweets this ad quote still processing
the possibility the North Korea will
have its first woman leader of for the
United States
they're just they're so woke do you know
north korea has actually had three Asian
leaders before America has even had one
hashtag woke hashtag progress hashtag
North Korea the left is so in thrall of
its identity politics ideology that they
think that North Korea is a symbol of
progress and emancipation and women's
liberation
it is a national prison camp and yet
they would have us be more like North
Korea and actually there's a lot of
logic to this because North Korea is a
country it's a nation founded on an
ideology it's one of the few communist
countries left on earth and the left has
always been very empathetic sympathetic
toward communism toward founding
governments on ideology so it's really
no surprise to me that they would have
some ideological connection here oh well
we'll take a look at the end of the show
to see what this means for international
politics moving forward but the left has
been defending communist regimes for a
very long time they did it for the
Soviet Union they did it for China they
still do it for China and they're doing
it even for North Korea which is
cartoonishly villainous and they should
be roundly mocked for this because if
anything the fact that North Korea has a
female leader is an argument against
female leaders not an argument for North
Korea okay I'm not saying I'm not saying
it's not it actually is an argument
against female leaders but if North
Korea is doing something your first
reaction should not be Wow
look how look how great that thing that
North Korea is doing it should have you
question it because North Korea is is
doing it itself and yet the left can't
do that because they're so enthralled of
this idea that anybody any woman in the
world would be a better president or
vice president or leader than a man you
see this with the Joe Biden campaign
saying I will pick a woman vice
president okay I'm not saying it's
necessarily a bad idea to have a woman
vice president but don't you think you
should pick the most qualified person
for the job
no the left has totally divorced that
practical Association but
wean the person and the job between
their governing strategy and reality it
is all ideology all the time it's all
the narrative and they are sanitizing
their own we will get to maybe the most
absurd hypocrisy on this kind of woke
identity politics ideology then we will
get to CNN which came out with the most
embarrassing article I have ever seen
we'll get to all of that in just a
moment but first I've got to thank you
I've got to thank you for subscribing if
you haven't subscribed yet already to
the daily wire join now now is the time
to do it you get a lot of great stuff
right you got all the shows and you get
to ask questions and you get to do the
all access and write whatever you get
this you get the leftist ears tumblr you
need this now more than ever especially
if the supreme leader of North Korea
dies off Kim Jong Un's gone is going to
be filled up with tears among the
American media so you get the one right
what if I told you you get two what if I
told you you get to double up
technically precisely two times as good
as the first offer if you become an
insider plus or all-access member right
now you can double your tears with two
leftist tears tumblers go to daily wire
calm slash subscribe
you want me to sweeten the pot you get
10% off two with coupon code no oil
scanner wles that is daily wire.com
slash subscribe coupon code Knowles you
get the rarest of all beverage vessels
times two we're actually doing this the
reason we're very interested we're
launching these all-access shows is
because I know that being trapped in
your home is unpleasant nobody likes
doing it it's difficult time so now
would be the time to do it join on in
hangout with us over here at the daily
wire head on over to the website we'll
be right back with a lot more
speaking of the inconsistencies of
ideology speaking of political
correctness there is a show about drag
queens I can't say I've watched it and
Jeff Goldblum was on it so there was
this one drag queen contestant who came
out there wearing a hijab you know sir
Muslim head covering with the American
flag stars on it and this is very
strange right because traditionally the
Muslim religion is not exactly open to
say Western liberalism or drag queens or
homosexuality or right or celebrating
women's liberation as we hear I
understand it in the West so there seems
to be a little bit of an inconsistency
here Jeff Goldblum who's guest-hosting
there comes out and asks this question
he's being absolutely eviscerated for it
as being so politically incorrect here's
his question are you religious may I ask
I'm not and to be honest this outfit
really represents the importance that
visibility for people of religious
minorities need to have in this country
isn't this an interesting wrinkle though
is there something in that religion that
is anti homosexuality and anti a woman
wha-ha-ha does that complicate the issue
I'm just raising you know thinking out
loud maybe being stupid but no no no
look maybe I'm look I know it's so crazy
and I'm just such an idiot for even
raising this obvious question but you
know aren't transvestites sort of
frowned upon in the Islamic faith which
is obviously true but you're not allowed
to raise that question in the West in
this leftist intersectional culture so
Jeff Goldblum he has to couch it in all
of these various ways and yet the
question is obviously true knitted
people have wondered this for a while
they say wait a second how is it that
Linda Sarsour and Gloria Steinem can
hold hands at the women's march against
Donald Trump
right these people don't exactly agree
on everything people who are Islamists
people who agree in a fundamental kind
of Islamic worldview and Sharia law they
tend not to exactly
along with feminists right they have
opposing understandings of the world
opposing ideologies opposing goals the
reason that you can have Islamic
fundamentalists on the same side as
homosexuals and transvestites on the
same side as feminists even just focus
on those latter two categories there
you've got the transgender movement and
the LG movement the gay and lesbian
movement on the same side and yet the
premise of transgenderism totally
undercuts the argument for homosexuality
right
homosexuality is based on the idea that
sex actually is innate you're born this
way and homosexuality is when boys are
attracted boys and girls are attracted
to girls but transgenderism says boys
can actually be girls and sex is just a
social construct anyway those two things
can't go together and yet they ally in
this kind of left-wing LGBT movement and
more broadly a movement that includes
Islamic fundamentalists like Linda
Sarsour and second wave feminists like
Gloria Steinem who also clearly would
disagree ideologically with
transgenderism it's just a hodgepodge of
ideas that don't work together and yet
they all a lie why because they have a
common enemy which is the conservative
tradition right they might not all agree
together
but they have this common foe which is
our own cultural inheritance our own
tradition here in the West which is
religious and cultural and political and
they want to tear that down so they alai
with one another you know conservatives
do this in a way to conservatives ally
will have the libertarians ally with the
traditionalists and with the religious
right and with the free speeches and
right all these people who might not
totally agree on everything but they
have a common enemy which is woke
leftism those are not coherent alliances
except they have the common foe and that
is what is really uniting the left right
now so they don't have to make sense of
what they're doing they don't it's fine
if their narrative is totally incoherent
it's fine if they go after Brett
Kavanaugh and say they believe all women
when it's convenient for them to attack
Republicans but they won't do it when
the accusers are going after Democratic
candidates for president we should not
expect coherence from them they're not
going to do it we have
deal with them on their own terms jeff
goldblum is raising this question I mean
fine fine to point out the hypocrisy but
that's not the point the point is not
what they all stand for it's what they
stand against that's why the conclusion
of Nancy Pelosi one day is going to be
that Trump shut down travel too fast the
next day it's going to be you didn't
shut down travel enough doesn't matter
because the goal for them is orange
man-bat the goal for them broadly and a
longer longer time line is undermine the
conservative American tradition that we
all know undermine the traditional
institutions that we all cherish that's
what they're going for and if it doesn't
make sense in the details they never
intended it to in the first place
speaking of things that don't make sense
in the details or more broadly I saw the
most embarrassing thing I've ever read
on CNN just yesterday this is a letter
written by the chief CNN environmental
correspondent bill weir he writes to my
son born in the time of coronavirus and
climate change
my dearest river he is writing from
Brooklyn of course against all odds you
were conceived in a lighthouse born
during a pandemic and will taste just
enough of life as we knew it all caps to
resent us when it's gone I'm sorry
actually you know what I can I can go on
maybe I'll touch on a few more parts but
bill actually read it for himself as a
CNN segment let's listen to him in his
own words
my dearest River you were conceived at a
lighthouse born into a pandemic and will
taste just enough of life as we know it
to resent us when it's gone I'm sorry
I'm sorry that we broke your see and
your sky and that your mother was forced
to give you your first kiss through a
p100 mask that smelled like smoke but my
boy we were warned scientists told us if
we weren't careful we wouldn't unleash
an invisible enemy out of the jungles
and into our lungs but we kept cutting
down the jungles to devour everything
inside and when we realized those
scientists were right scared people
emptied store shelves even faster than
the jungles and all the invisible enemy
masks were gone just in time for your
birth okay hold up so here are the first
absurdity is that this guy is blaming
pollution for coronavirus right he's
blaming the environmental destruction in
global warming for coronavirus but we
know that pollution didn't cause
coronavirus coronavirus was caused by
some combination of bat soup and the
Wuhan Institute of Virology and the
Chinese cover-up we know that for sure
we know that it was not caused by
plastic straws and yet he's using that
he's trying to blame pollution because
pollution is a stand-in for sin broadly
in the religion of environmentalism and
that is a false religion and that's why
it's giving a false explanation of the
virus he goes on I was about to gulp and
pay a soulless profiteer 600 bucks for a
50 cent mask when I remembered the one I
used to protect my lungs from a fiery
place called California
I keep it next to my hurricane waiters
and my bulletproof vest with a patch
that says press and if I have to pack
them and kiss you good-bye more often
than you'd like I'm sorry but we were
warned warned about what now he is
bringing up forest fires as if forest
fires are not naturally occurring forest
fires do occur actually the reason that
we now have more forests in North
America than we did before European
exploration is because now we are much
better at managing forest fires than we
were before the Europeans got here back
when it was still Native Americans who
would burn down whole forests far less
in a far less controlled manner than the
European settlers would do also fires in
California including in my own
neighborhoods are usually caused by
homeless camps they've caused many of
the fires in California and something
tells me that CNN and the left don't
particularly want to do anything about
that but the one thing I can tell you is
that climate change broadly is not the
proximate cause of forest fires all
right they've existed a long time also
this guy is a journalist not a fireman
if it requires me to go out there leave
you more more often than I'd like it's
just what I have to do no you don't have
to do it you're not helping anybody
you're spreading lies on CNN you could
get a much more noble job namely any job
so if you want to stay home with your
kids stay on with your kid that's fine
oh my gosh he's got they just that CNN
in particular but all of these guys is
leftist journalists always want to make
themselves the story Chris Cuomo the
other day spent much of his show just
talking about himself as he always does
they're not that special they're not
that important the only thing they're
doing is spreading lies anyway so get
another job if you don't like it then he
tells us about how the scientists warned
us scientists told us if we weren't
careful we would unleash a different
kind of invisible enemy out of our
factories and farms and homes and cars
and it would get into the sea in the sky
and change life as we know it but that
was a story too few wanted to believe
until now yeah
we didn't believe well not until now we
didn't believe it then and we don't
believe it now because the models kept
not being true right nothing about
coronavirus has changed that
if anything the coronavirus has made us
even more skeptical of models because
those models weren't true either
coronavirus now has made a skeptical of
epidemiology as well as climatology two
of the fakest Sciences that exist to
have the least reliable I should say
Sciences that exist if you can call them
Sciences at all right because in in the
case of the corona virus a completely
different set of scientists got those
models wrong if anything all of this has
taught us to be much more wary of the
prophecies of our secular priests who
are the exalted experts then he gets to
a point that is mildly interesting
because that's within something he knows
about and that is how we tell stories so
your first lesson will be that we are
human and humans are made of stories and
the great thing about stories is that
they are always under revision you were
conceived in a lighthouse ok how many
times is this guy going to tell us that
he boinked his wife in a lighthouse you
don't need to tell us that I get that
he's bragging or something that's fine
but you don't need to make that the
light motif of the entire story you're
supposed to be talking about
environmentalism so talk about that now
I've just got this image of the CNN guy
getting busy in a lighthouse I'm sorry I
shouldn't have interrupted he goes on so
we will raise you with the soul of a
lighthouse keeper dependable vigilant
with a reverence for the power of nature
and a commitment to save as much life as
possible what does that mean
what because this guy got weird and
frisky with his wife in a lighthouse
we're gonna raise you with soul of the
lighthouse keeper and you keep the light
and this is if you're talking about
telling good stories this is not a great
way to tell a story this is like
weaksauce from a freshman high school
English class okay I don't I guess
that's enough to qualify you for CNN
he's not much much like all the other
leftist narratives here this one it's
not holding up it's not making a whole
lot of sense and yet he goes on to extol
the virtues of better stories and I'll
try to teach you how to write a better
story don't hold your breath kid because
I don't think daddy's gonna be able to
teach you a whole lot about creative
writing then he he does finally get to
the point that's the last point that he
makes and it's the only one that really
teaches us something
he gets to a point about ideology one
that reminds everyone that every day is
Earth Day there it is there is the mark
of the ideologue no matter what he's
talking about no matter where it comes
from
every question always comes back to his
narrow abstracted rationalistic idea in
this case the idea of Earth Day every
day is Earth Day
the coronavirus just shows us that we
need to stop polluting how it doesn't
show he's never made the argument for
that and of course he couldn't make the
argument for that because the
coronavirus didn't come from straws
going in the nose of sea turtles it came
from Wuhan
and a Chinese cover-up and very likely a
laboratory that is the mark of the
ideologue it always keeps coming back to
those issues and you see it it actually
is much more overwrought if you want to
read the letter at cnn.com music
he has winning lines like I'm sorry that
the Great Barrier Reef is no longer
great that we value Amazon more than the
Amazon oh my gosh what weak prose but
then he says we kept cutting down the
jungles and the prairies to pave and
plow develop and devour everything
inside as you get older this will be
hard to understand but we were under the
spell of Genesis 1:28 to take dominion
over every living thing there is the
mark of the ideology right ideology
replaces traditional modes of thought
and religions with the religion of ideas
and everybody has got to serve somebody
everybody's got to have a type of
religion the trouble is in modern life
most people who would say that they're
atheistic or spiritual but not religious
or whatever euphemism you want to use
they are in the thrall of religions of
ideas in this case he's in thrall of the
religion of environmentalism he first of
all he completely misunderstands Genesis
which says that we have dominion over
the land and the sea we are to be
stewards of that he misunderstands that
and he's saying explicitly we need to
replace Christianity with this new
religion of environmentalism the
religion of Earth day I make this point
every time it comes up people still
don't believe me environmentalism
leftism more broadly as an ideology is a
substitute religion it gives people
every single answer that they want but
it's a false religion founded on a false
anthropology founded on a false
understanding of human nature and nature
itself they the nature of our
environment and because of that it gets
everything wrong here laughably it gets
wrong the coronavirus but it gets so
much else wrong as well speaking of
leftists before we go getting human
nature wrong you remember
New York City shuts down they let a ton
of people out of prison right they're
letting so many inmates out of prison
actually just outside the city north of
New York they let a bunch of child
rapists out of prison they thought that
was a good idea even in New York they're
letting a lot of violent criminals out
there idea they're misunderstanding of
human nature is that if you let these
people out during the coronavirus
they'll be really well behaved and
they'll be you just don't be grateful
and they'll be responsible and that's a
good thing right now for people who have
a little more clear-eyed understanding
of human nature we say you know the
thing to do in a pandemic the thing to
do first probably not let a bunch of
criminals out onto the street right
because I think crime is gonna spike
well guess what happened crime has
spiked in New York over the last twenty
eight days in the middle of the lockdown
murders in New York are up fifty five
percent compared to this time last year
over the week from April 13th to the
19th murders increased 100 percent over
that same week last year and
year-to-date
so going all the way back to January
murders are up 5.7 percent other crimes
- grand larceny auto has increased 53
percent compared to last year there have
been five hundred charges for auto theft
there in the last 28 days which is way
up over 2019
burglaries are up twenty twenty five
percent over the last 28 days and
they're up more than 36 percent over the
last week so the problem is getting a
whole lot worse an accused rapist who
was released from Rikers Island which
New York wanted to they were saying we
got empty at Rikers Island this guy
Robert Pondexter was arrested for
allegedly raping a woman in Brooklyn
just days after he was released because
of the corona virus these are the real
stories from the virus these are the
real story
that are not being covered in the media
because the media just wants to talk to
you about the Lysol comment because the
media just wants to talk to you about
how Trump he overreacted or he under
reacted or he cut off too many Chinese
travelers or he didn't cut off enough
Chinese travelers they they want to make
this all about President Trump and
attack him fret often for two different
things two opposite things at the same
time because they have to sanitize their
own narrative a narrative which day by
day on every single point is falling
apart and leaving mayhem in its wake all
right now the the way to do this is not
to defend every single comment that the
White House is making or to just say
actually they got this wrong and this or
even to argue that you know the
Democrats have committed sexual assault
like Joe Biden the meetyou movement the
way to make that argument is just to
take that light that we're all shining
on the Trump stuff on the conservative
side and just shine that light right
back on the left because the misdeeds of
the left the collapse of the leftist
narrative is far more egregious all we
have to do is shine that light on it
maybe from the lighthouse in which that
CNN writer got weird with his wife I
don't know I don't know but we have to
shine a light on it in any case that's
our show I'm Michael Moses the Michael
Nolt show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stevens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka geneva
production assistant ryan love the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over the Andrew clay
bird show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clifford
[Music]